you said you don't trust Paul because
Paul made believe that Jesus was God
alongside the father and you brought a
verse from Isaiah to shows how Yahweh
says that there's no God besides him
well here still in Isaiah shows how the
son is God too along with the
father okay good point I'll let you have
it Paul is in line with the prophets
right
no before we start can you do me a favor
depends maybe do a little prayer to God
Alone to guide you open up your eyes yes
yes I start may I start okay Lord heaven
Lord of Heaven and Earth Father Son and
Holy Spirit may you please guide this
conversation gu us into all truth lead
me and Empower me to speak with truth
and accuracy with humility and
humbleness and patience and I pray Lord
God Yahweh father Son and Holy Spirit
that you open the heart of the sister
that has come up to join the
conversation that she may receive your
truth and be open to your truth and
submit to your truth Lord in Jesus name
we pray amen so you have to do it and um
you have to blashe and add somebody else
besides God during your prayer what do
you mean blashe I pray to The One and
Only God no you use Jesus's name yeah
he's the one
God to me it's it's blasphemy to do it
to you it's blasphemy yeah it's
blasphemy can you do it to God alone
like the creator of the Heaven and the
Earth without using Jesus's name I can't
because then I won't be praying to the
god of Heaven and Earth if I can't who's
who's the creator Jesus okay can you
just okay so you're not gonna do it I
without stating his name I did do you
you did it using Jesus's name well Jesus
never used even used that name does that
make sense never used the name Jesus
yeah he did look this is John chapter
14 um John chapter 14
look how he tells us to pray he says
whatever you ask in my name this I will
do that the father may be glorified in
the son if you ask me anything in my
name I will do it John 14: 13- 14 all
right all right but he never used the
name Jesus what was his Aramaic name is
what I'm stating yesh well I'm here to
just answer your question
um I don't dislike Paul I don't trust
him and I have reasons
all right what's what's the first reason
why you don't trust God first reason is
that he took us away from testifying in
one God and made people needing to
testify in a human being for their
salvation um and let me back it up with
a verse for example in Isaiah 455 God
says I am the Lord and there's no other
apart from me there is no God I will
strengthen you but though you have not
acknowledged me okay and then
Deuteronomy 6:4 God talks about you know
here Israel the Lord is one but then Jes
um Paul says um yet for us there is but
one God the father from all from whom
all things came and whom we live and
there is but one Lord Jesus Christ so he
added Jesus along with God so that's the
first reason the second reason wait wait
let's let's doal with that do that one
at a time um I'm glad you're reading the
Old Testament to see what the prophets
say can you go to isaah you quoted isaah
can you go to Isaiah chapter 9 now go to
verse 6 or to us a child is born to us a
son is given and the government will be
on his shoulders and he will be called
wonderful counselor Mighty God
Everlasting father Prince of Peace so do
you see how Isaiah revealed that the son
to be born is the Mighty God
I would have to go back and see the
original uh translation I'm not very
well
versed you know Hebrew and whatnot so I
don't know I don't trust that
translation well well the Hebrew says
elore Mighty God I can show you on the
screen if you want I can pull it up the
Hebrew it's actually a good idea so let
me pull that up for you really quick I
read Arabic so I'm able to understand
what's in the Quran alhamdulillah it's
great yeah I'm just commenting all right
here's the Hebrew the top with the
translation at the
bottom that's so interesting Hebrew is
so close to Arabic like in Arabic it's
used in the word like it's very similar
y very similar to Arabic it's so
interesting for a child is born unto us
a son Ben is given unto us it's I think
the same in right Ben unto us and will
be the government upon his shoulder and
will be called his name p which is
wonderful
y counselor El gior which is God Mighty
the Mighty God L is God in Hebrew gibor
Mighty and abiad which is ABI is Father
ad is Everlasting so Everlasting father
Prince SAR Shalom Prince or ruler of
Peace yeah none of those explicitly say
God what are you talking about I don't
know yeah it says God so the son to be
born to us is God himself all right let
me tell you the second reason why I wait
wait wait wait wait we got to we got I
mean I I don't trust that translation it
doesn't what do you mean I showed you
the Hebrew yeah but it's not like I
don't understand Hebrew so I would have
to go you know but I I I I showed it to
you showed me the you showed me the
Hebrew but it doesn't say like or it
just says L like in Arabic is is is
equivalent to
the so Arabic is not
they're similar though they're similar
but they're not the same l in Hebrew is
God El GI Mighty God I just showed it to
you what does God mean in Hebrew we have
many words for it there's El
Elohim say eloh Elohim is the plural
form of L or ELO okay I don't see it but
okay Elohim is plural and you have the e
at the end of the word it's the plural
form of the word yeah but you have you
have Isaiah 96 now this is what's
interesting to me my sisters that you
quoted Isaiah 45 and you didn't bother
to check the Hebrew on that um you
wasn't skeptical about that verse but
you're skeptical about this verse in the
same book by the same author by the same
Prophet you know that shows an
inconsistency there you can't just side
with something because you believe it
matches what you already assumed and
believe yourself with your own religion
you got I simply prefer things to be
more
explicit explicit it says Mighty God
there's you can't get more explicit okay
I need to go to Google Translate and see
what it says what do you need to go to
Google Translate for I took you to the
Hebrew Interlinear you don't need Google
translate yeah okay I took you why you
scared why are you scared of me going
into it you can do what you want I'm
just I just I just find it interesting
the the the level of skepticism I
very I'm very skeptic it's okay to be
skep well you're not though because why
why wasn't you skeptical of Isaiah 455
question I'm skeptical of everything
it's just um except Isaiah 455 why are
you not skeptical of that verse because
it's explicit it's straightforward so is
this it says that the son to be born his
name is called The Mighty God it's
straightforward it's explicit what's
what's not I am going to the Hebrew text
right now taking the word I'm trying to
I'm trying to see I'm trying to see
where you're at what is not explicit
about him clearly explicitly being
called Mighty God what is not explicit
about that hello yeah I'm trying to
translate it one second one second
and gior okay I've never heard that
being used as a word for God gior is
mighty not God gibor means Mighty Hebrew
L is word for God I'll all right um my
second Point wait there's no second
Point yet let's finish so you see how I
yeah I see what you mean yeah I see what
you mean so TR it it doesn't not St wait
wait wait I'm sorry cuz I'm I'm just I'm
making you I'm going with your standard
you said you don't trust Paul because
Paul made believe that Jesus is God
alongside the father and and and and you
you brought a verse from Isaiah to shows
how Yahweh says that there's no God
besides him well here still in Isaiah
shows how the son is God too along with
the
father okay good point I'll let you have
it Paul is in line with the prophets
right
no we we just we just saw that let me
let me show you why he's not again let
me show you my second Point you're not
letting me go through okay at least on
the first point he's in line with I told
you I'll give it to you I told you I'll
give it to you I'll give it to you let
me go let me go to the second Point wait
but I have I have a question now I have
a question now okay because we're our
our standard is the prophets if if
somebody is not in line with the
prophets we can't we can't trust them
right that's number one okay does is
Muhammad in line with the prophets that
Jesus is God along with the father no
then you can't trust Muhammad get it
Jesus himself never never claimed to be
God bro I just showed you where Jesus
said praying in his name remember I
showed you that okay that's him claiming
to be God right saying we could pray in
his name I don't trust the whole Greek
bible so that's another point but you
did you trusted the Bible enough to say
I don't trust Paul for this reason
here's number one no listen listen I
can't use my Quran I I have my reasons
why I trust my Quran right I'm just
saying I can't use my Quran to help you
understand why I don't like Paul there's
a lot of reasons from the Quran why I
don't like Paul right but I'm using it
because you trust your Old Testament so
I used it reason why I referenced so you
were so you were telling me why I cuz
you you said that that the reason why
you don't trust Paul is one because he
contradicts Isaiah he contradicted the
prophet exactly he does yeah okay so
does Muhammad contradict the prophet
what we see the prophet teach here does
he contradict it yeah um so the Quran
does tell us to judge based on what the
Quran has revealed so yes I would say it
I would say in the quran's teachings it
possibly does contradict that verse that
you showed me in Isaiah 96 that's right
so if it contradicts if it contradicts
what the prophet says if Muhammad
contradicts the previous Prophet then
Muhammad is not to be trusted just like
and like I said again the Quran says woe
to those who write with their own hands
and say it from God so I don't fully
trust you know didn't they write the and
New Testament wait didn't they write the
Quran with their own hands and say was
from God that's God's words didn't they
write it write it they did but it's
recited so was the so is the Old
Testament the old and God said that he
would preserve on and Jesus said Jesus
said the same thing Jesus said my words
will never pass away he said Heaven and
Earth will pass away but my words will
never pass away all right so let's go to
my second Point all right I'm just
saying if you're gonna if you're gonna
say that's the reason to not trust Paul
then that means not trust Paul can we go
to can we go to my second point if you
if you do you understand the first point
yes I understand it I get why you
understand it the way you do you're
saying you're saying that I you're
saying that why you shouldn't trust
Muhammad no no absolutely not I have
100% certainty in the Quran
alhamdulillah all right I I have enough
time for your second Point what's what's
your second the second one is about law
and justification so in the Old
Testament and through Jesus's teachings
he tells us that we have to do works and
then Paul on the other hand kind of ears
away from that and I can show you verses
um like in Deuteronomy
6:25 um we have to fulfill the
Commandments we have to do what God has
commanded us same thing with um Matthew
5:17 to19 you know he said he did not
come to abolish the law also Matthew
7:21 you have to submit your will to God
um and chapter Matthew chapters 5-7
Jesus um on the sermon Sermon on the
Mount teaches about all the things that
you have to
do I got like two minutes no problem no
problem Paul on the other hand says in
Romans 3:28 for we hold that one is
justified by faith apart from works of
Allah and to me the is contradictory to
what the Old Testament teaches and what
Jesus had taught okay um and the same
thing with Galatians 3:11 it is let's do
got to do it one so I only got time for
one so Romans 3 can you read verse 31 of
Romans 3 Romans 3 can I read it from 27
yes please when then is boasting it is
excluded because of what law the law
requires work or we maintain that a
person justified by faith apart from the
works of the law or is God the god of
Jews only is he not the god of G to he
is since there is only one God who will
justify the circumcised by faith and the
uncircumcised through the same do we
then NY the law by okay I see I see
where he does say that we should uphold
the law okay that's good to see good to
see all right I definitely enjoyed I
would love to talk to you more but I do
have to start my live stream on YouTube
problem please come back because it
sounds like you have you know some
questions and some arguments so I want
to hear them and I want see if I
can sounds good have a good take care of
yourself God bless you